[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka chris twatt and
this video we're breaking down the
tomorrow war
the new amazon prime movie has a lot
going on with it and throughout this
we'll be going over its plot
ending and comments made by director
chris mckay on what the film is actually
about
bald spoilers ahead so if you don't want
to know what happens or how you die
then i highly suggest that you turn off
now if you do want to know then click
the thumbs up button and subscribe
because we'll be telling you later in
the video
now without the way you're obviously
very excited thanks for clicking this
now let's get into the tomorrow war okay
so the tomorrow war begins in december
2022
and in it we follow a character called
dan played by chris pratt
dan did two combat tours with the
military but he found his passion in the
research lab which led to him becoming a
science teacher
during the world cup finale time
travelers arrived to tell us that not
only is it coming home
but that there's also a war in the
future in which humanity
has been almost completely eradicated in
the movie we learn that these monsters
known as the white spikes
were brought over as cargo on an alien
ship that crash-landed in russia
frozen and ice for years these
eventually unthawed
and were unleashed on the population
destroying most of humanity
there's worse timeline sacrals like like
the one where justice league is still
canon
but in a last-ditch attempt to save
humanity the humans of the future have
traveled back in time to recruit us
in their war to save earth bloody kids
of the future
can't even fight their own wars without
us now this war of future past
has an extremely high death count and
less than 20 percent return from
fighting the white spikes
those that do are left with severe ptsd
issues
and because of this the topic of it is
quite a controversial one
now the film doesn't really discuss how
time travel works overtly
but we do learn that there is a tether
in the past and future that people can
travel between
however these points aren't really
static and as the movie goes on
we learn that if one is to change the
past that it drastically alters the
future
the movie never out and out says it but
clearly those enlisted have
either had children or are old enough to
the point that they've lived most of
their life
therefore if they are killed in the
future the people of the future will
still be born
and there won't be a grandfather paradox
in which someone isn't born because
their ancestor was killed in the future
and thus unable to return to the past to
conceive them
let me know if that doesn't make sense
but moving on now due to the way that
the events happen in the film
we do know that there is one timeline
and that it is possible to change the
trajectory of the future
by altering the past the kids of 2022
seem pretty depressed the human race is
going to be more dead than alice and
mack's career
but dan seems hopeful that it is
possible to change things
however he is called into the draft and
we learn that dan
is due to die in seven years time and
thus he's more than adequate to fight in
the future war without messing things up
dan initially tries to dodge the draft
and he goes to his father james
who can disable the temporal implants
that are bolted onto troops to make sure
they don't flee
played by jay jonah jackson jk looks
like he could take down spider-man
himself
god damn man looking like tuna santa
with extra protein god damn
now the pair are estranged after james
abandoned him as a child
however this idea of fathers and their
children is echoed throughout the film
we learned that dan ended up leaving his
family and that he died in a car
accident
so in some ways it's like poetry they
rhyme dan very much ended up becoming
his father
but this opportunity to know how things
play out gives him a different
perspective
when talking to den of geek director
chris mckay said that the true meaning
of the movie is about fathers
and how deep down most of them would do
anything for their children
even if they aren't always there dan
going off to fight in the future war in
some ways echoes his father james who
left him when he was younger after
suffering ptsd
due to vietnam it's clear that the war
changed him and james feels like it
would have been worse if he'd stayed
in many ways the best interests of his
son decided his actions
but dan sees him very much as being a
coward that was willing to run away
dan doesn't want to make the same
mistakes as his dad who fled from things
and because of this he decides to go and
fight in the war in order to provide his
daughter with a better future
now dan's child is a central figure in
the film and after he travels to the
future he comes face to face with his
daughter murie
who is fighting aliens herself before he
found out this though yeah
you could see you could see that he
almost contemplated banging his
own daughter but i digress now the
future parts are absolutely incredible
and the first 90 minutes of the film are
really really gripping
i feel like the movie perfectly captures
the tone of things like edge of tomorrow
and
live die repeat what what do you mean
it's the same movie now on top of this
there's also elements like aliens
starship troopers and a lot more to make
this a really fun ride that had me
totally on board for these moments
however mckay said he also took
inspiration from it's a wonderful life
there is this idea at the core that dan
has been given a second chance to do
things the right way
knowing what happens to him ironically
he denies a second chance to his father
when he goes to see him earlier in the
movie
but i think the feature very much gives
in the foresight to see that he's just
as flawed as his dad
now the white spike design is also very
unique and you can see why the people of
the future wouldn't tell anyone in the
past what they were fighting against
because
it would stop people enlisting the
dialogue is really good too
and as always chris pratt gives a great
every man performance
that makes it easy to see things through
his eyes as he's thrust into this
terrifying future
there's also great thai characters such
as charlie and dorian
who sort of juxtapose one another with
one having an upbeat attitude
whilst the other one has come to die
overall though we discovered that miri
has brought her father to the future for
a reason
and they attempt to capture a female
white spike so they can study why she's
immune to toxins
this mission is a success though just
barely
and dan has to step in to save his
daughter now from here they travel to a
research base
and develop a way to kill the female so
that they aren't able to breed
and thus the species can be controlled
turns out miri wants her dad to take the
toxin back into the past
and wipe out the current timeline in
order to build a better one
just in the same way that the past were
willing to sacrifice themselves to save
the future
miuri very much represents the future
wanting to sacrifice itself to save the
past
she's basically the tenor organization
and after the white stripes attacked the
base
murray is killed and dan probably won't
be abandoning her again after watching
her die before his very eyes in a moment
that would make quite a good scene in a
movie looks looks very very beautiful
that anyway
due to the enlistment only lasting seven
days dan is pulled back to the past and
he and his wife figure out that the
white spikes were always there
through a kid called martin that just so
happens to be obsessed with ancient
volcanoes
they discover the location of their
spawn point now dan tries to warn the
government
but the bloody government you know how
they are they don't actually like doing
things whilst they still can
and they refuse to investigate russia
thus dan goes rogue with his father and
some soldiers he met in the past
as well as the feature resistance leader
now unfortunately i kind of feel like
this third act sort of fumbles the ball
a bit
and it definitely doesn't feel as strong
as the prior two the group find the ship
buried far beneath the ice
and here they discover that the white
spikes may have even been used as
weapons
in order to launch a planetary invasion
kept in the cargo hold
dan and co inject the toxin whilst they
sleep but after some awaken
the others do too most notably the queen
if aliens taught us anything it's that
they're the most dangerous and after
blowing the ship
it's up to dan and his dad to take her
down the finale feels
very in line with the thing the ending
of the prequel one and though it kind of
devolves into all our action
i think the movie definitely has its
heart in the right place i also like
that the dad took time to make a snowman
with a face on it as bait
but i digress now there is kind of too
much jumping about and the monster
constantly coming back after it seems
like it's dead
but eventually dan manages to kill it
after his dad uses himself as a
distraction
he shouts die and i'm glad that they
said this was corny because
if they had enough i might have turned
the movie off anyway
all happy endings and the government of
course claimed they carried out the op
and they get the glory but back home dan
gets something better
his dad meets his granddaughter and dan
now makes the promise that he will never
leave his family
because the best feature he could have
is right in front of him
it's a very upbeat ending that lets us
know we can make the right choices
and though i did have issues with the
third act i feel this was a pretty
strong message for a movie that could
have been just another by the numbers
action film
overall i had a lot of fun with tomorrow
war and although everyone did a really
great job in their roles
though the final act did drop the ball a
bit for me the first hour was really
something
i think a lot of people will probably
enjoy the movie overall i'd give it
probably six
six or a seven out of ten but if you're
from amazon
and you want to give me some more voice
over work then it's a 10 out of 10.
10 stars and a ribbon to wrap around it
now
as as for how you will die which i
promise i'd tell you
turns out yeah you're gonna die from
excessive click bait
from the channel heavy spoilers so
congratulations on that and in the
meantime i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the movie so make sure you comment
below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of july
in which you pick three random comments
that get an mcu box set of their choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
loki episode 4
which will be linked on screen right now
i've also done some voice over work for
amazon discussing
why i love invincible and that will be
linked on screen right now too so
get yourself over there anyway without
the way thank you for singing through
the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace